بدات الحرب باعلان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ما وصفها بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه
لتحديد سلاح اوكرانيا وافراغها ممن سماهم
النازيين ومنذ الايام الاولى للحرب ومع
توجه الرجال الى الجبهات تدفق مئات الالاف
من اللاجئين من النساء والاطفال على دول
الجوار في ازمه لاجئين اخرى تضرب اوروبا
على الجبهه اشتد القصف وتسارع تقدم القوات
الروسيه في محاور وتباطا في اخرى لكن
انسحابها من بلده بوشا شمال كيف كشف عن
عشرات المقابر الجماعيه وسط تمديد دول
غربيه بما وصفتها الوحشيه الروسيه في مايو
تركزت الانظار على مصنع الحديد في
ماريوبول حيث استمات المقاتلون
الاوكرانيون في الدفاع عنه تحت وبل من
القصف الروسي لكنها مقاومه انتهت
بالاستسلام
حبس مفاعلها النووي انفاس العالم اكثر من
مره وتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات بالمسؤوليه
عن قصف محيط المفاعل الاكبر في اوروبا
والذي يهدد اي تسرب نووي فيه القاره
باسرها في وقت تستمر فيه الدعوات لافراغ
محيطه من المقاتلين اخبار سعيده بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين حملها شهر سبتمبر حيث انسحبت
القوات الروسيه من خاركيف بعد معارك طاحنه
في نصر كان الاوكرانيون في امس الحاجه
اليه انسحاب دفع وزير الدفاع الروسي الى
اعلان التعبئه الجزئيه واستدعاء مئات
الالاف من الجنود في ظل زخم تدريجي بدات
القوات الاوكرانيه في اكتساب
[موسيقى]
مناطق دنيا
تحت سيادتها بعد اجراء استفتاءات شككت في
مصداقيتها اوكرانيا ومعها الدول الغربيه
في الثامنه من اكتوبر استيقظ العالم على
تفجير جسر القرم الرابط بين الاراضي
الروسيه وشبه الجزيره التي ضمتها روسيا
عام 2014 في ضربه كانت موجعه التفجير اغضب
الروسي وردت عليه موسكو بعد يومين بحمله
قصف مكثف استهدفت محطات الكهرباء في
العاصمه كييف غرقت بعدها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه في الظلام لاسابيع واقع لم ينل
من معنويات القوات الاوكرانيه التي نجحت
في تحقيق تقدم في مدينه خرسون انتهى
باستعاده السيطره على المدينه في الثاني
عشر من نوفمبر في الاشهر التاليه ومع
الشداد البرد وتاثير الصقيع على سير
المعارك دخلت الحرب مرحله لم يستطع فيها
اي طرف تحقيق اختراق ويقول مراقبون انه
واقع لن يستمر طويلا مع استمرار تجهيز
الروس لهجوم في الربيع واستعداد اوكراني
مسنود باسلحه نوعيه قادمه من